how's it going everyone it's Warren and
it's Thursday so you know what that
means it's time for theory Thursday's
segment where you all submit your
theories and I pick five each week to go
over and then you all vote for your
favorite theory for the week and then at
the end of the month out of all the
theories that one each week you all vote
on your favorite theory to win the month
and the monthly prize right now the
current monthly prize is two imax
tickets to the winner so you can go see
Avengers in game with a friend last
week's winner was Aidan Jost with how he
thinks Avengers and games going to play
out Congrats Aidan you're now in the
pool of Champions and have a chance to
win the monthly prize all right let's
dive into some theories our first one
comes from Erin Kelly it has a theory
about war machine and Captain Marvel
Erin says that Rhodey and Carol are
probably of similar age and they
probably know each other since they were
both in the Air Force Erin thinks we'll
see a roadie cameo in Captain Marvel and
in fact he thinks that it's likely that
he is one of the boys that Maria is
referring to in the higher further
faster big game spot
Erin says that with fury being gone rody
is going to be a bridge between the
Avengers and Captain Marvel when she
shows up for endgame he says we also
might see a little spark of the romance
between these two characters like they
have in the comics but it's already a
very full movie so he's not holding his
breath on that making the cut I gotta
say this theory makes a lot of sense we
know that Rhodey given his rank has been
in the Air Force for a very long time
and him and Carol aren't too different
in age so they have probably overlapped
each other at some point in time and it
wouldn't make sense to see a cameo from
him in Captain Marvel and seeing how
none of the Avengers who are alive right
now know who Carol is and Rhodey does he
is going to be the most likely one to
introduce them so this theory could very
well happen all right that does it for
number one let's head on to Theory
number two number two comes from TJ
Parker and it's a short and very simple
theory regarding Avengers in game what
if and Avengers in game Tony and nebula
are building something big to defeat
Thanos what if they're not planning on
getting back to earth but somehow nebula
knows where Titan 2 is I can definitely
see how after the events of Avengers
infinity war Tony and nebula would go
see
thanos they're obviously going to be
very desperate after the events nebula
lost most of the guardians of the galaxy
she doesn't know if rocket and Groot are
alive and Tony Stark lost Doctor Strange
and Peter Parker who was basically like
a son to him so I can definitely see
that in their desperation they would
attempt to find Thanos and attempt to
make a weapon that could be powerful
enough to beat him and we have heard
some plot leaks that say Tony and nebula
actually go and find Thanos and he ends
up sending them back to earth so you
never know this plot leaked could end up
being true and this theory could tie
right into it so that does it for theory
number two on to number three number
three comes from John shank who has a
theory about the sacrifices in Avengers
and games specifically in regards to
Captain America it's a very interesting
theory in which John says what if
Captain America goes to retrieve the
soul stone and obviously the soul 'some
requires a sacrifice in order to
retrieve it the thing you love the most
so what if Captain America sacrifices
his compass that has the picture of
Peggy Carter on it which is his last
memory of Peggy has one true love and
this is why we see him with the compass
in the Avengers in game trailer I
definitely would not put it past Captain
America to take it upon himself to go
and search for the soul stone and if the
soul stone would require another
sacrifice
I don't think Captain America would
sacrifice another person I do think that
he loves Peggy Carter the most but
obviously she's not there to sacrifice
and that compass probably does mean a
lot to Steve Rogers and if he does end
up searching for the soul stone and
finds it maybe the soul stone would
accept that as a sacrifice and we do all
wonder why Steve Rogers was looking at
that picture in the Avengers end game
trailer perhaps this theory could
explain it and perhaps Captain America
knows what he asked the sacrifice we'll
have to wait till Avengers end game
comes out to find out so that is theory
number three on to number four theory
number four comes from Siobhan dave and
Siobhan has a theory about the aftermath
of Avengers in game specifically
focusing on the original Avengers and
who will take their places
Siobhan thinks that somehow Captain
America will die possibly jumping on an
explosive and Tony Stark will live and
become a mentor to the New Avengers that
are coming in Siobhan thinks that this
would be very fitting because Captain
America
never attire and Tony becoming the
mentor to everybody would show how much
he's grown Thor finally settles down and
becomes the king of Asgard maybe with a
spouse such as Valkyrie or maybe Jane
Foster Natasha and Clint will retire and
possibly form the long-awaited love life
that the fans have wanted depending on
how Avengers end game ends and of course
they could pop up as mentors as well The
Hulk either dies or he becomes a
peaceful hermit like he was before
Siobhan then thinks that either Harley
from Iron Man 3
Bucky or Falcon should be the new
Captain America
Siobhan then thanks that if Tony and
Pepper end up having a girl she would
eventually grow up and take the mantle
of Iron Man becoming iron woman and then
Clint's kids would go on to become new
versions of Hawkeye and Black Widow
so we definitely know that there won't
be the original Avengers after the
events of Avengers endgame so this
theory does have some merit because they
are going to have to bring in new people
especially if some characters die or
retire and I do think that some of these
things could definitely happen such as
Iron Man having a daughter and her
growing up to take on the mantle of Iron
Man and I do think that either Bucky or
Falcon will be next to take on the
mantle of Captain America because it
does happen in the comics they've both
taken up that mantle so parts of this
theory could very well end up happening
after the events of Avengers endgame so
that does it for theory number 4 on to
theory number 5 our final theory comes
from Leonardo who has a theory about how
the beginning of Avengers and game could
play out Tony and nebula are on the
Bennet are and they're heading for Earth
they're fine for a few days until Tony's
food and water runs out right when he is
about to run out of oxygen an escape pod
from the Statesmen shows up with some of
the Asgardians on it along with some of
the Sakura --nz they get on the ship
with the rest of these guardians and
thus occurence and head back to earth
with them and they go to Norway where
Odin died eventually Thor and rocket
find out that Tony Stark is back on
earth and they go to Norway meanwhile
Tony and nebula are in a nearby shed
making a new Iron Man suit out of Tony's
helmet and some scraps that were lying
around in the shed and on the benatar
Thor reunites with Valkyrie and rocket
seized the shed in the nearby distance
and goes and decides to check it out he
finds nebula and Tony and nebula tells
Tony all about rocket
valkyrie Tony nebula Thor and rocket all
go back to the Avengers HQ at the
Avengers facility Tony Stark goes into a
storage room and finds some of his barf
tech he uses it on nebula to find out
why she wants to get revenge on Thanos
Tony sees the memories of Thanos
adopting nebula nebulas fights with
Gamora an Thanos torturing nebula to get
Gamora to tell him where the soul stone
was nebula keeps working on the Iron Man
suit while Tony Stark talks to rocket
and the other Avengers we do know that
there are escape pods out there from the
Statesmen the Russo brothers did confirm
this and we have seen some leaked toys
of Valkyrie so we know she'll be an
Avengers end game so it is possible that
the escape pod that they're on could run
into Tony and nebula on their way back
to earth and it is highly expected that
Thor was going to Norway to build new
Asgard so that's most likely where
they're going and we have seen in the
trailer Tony and nebula working on
something it could be a new Iron Man
suit so there is a possibility of this
theory playing out in Avengers end game
so that does it for this week's theories
let's do a quick recap theory number one
was that Captain Marvel and war machine
have actually met before and war machine
is going to be the person to introduce
Captain Marvel to the rest of the
Avengers theory number two is that Tony
and nebula are building something big to
defeat Thanos and are heading to Titan
to Theory number three is that Captain
America will sacrifice his compass and
picture of Peggy to get the soul stone
theory number four is about the
aftermath of Avengers in game and who
will take the place of the original
Avengers theory number five is about the
aftermath of Avengers in game and how
Valkyrie will find Tony and nebula and
that does it for this week's theories be
sure to vote on which one you thought
was your favorite and if you would like
to submit a theory of your own for a
chance to end up in an episode you can
find the directions and the instructions
in the description down below
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss an episode and so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]